in the midst of doing mcc and um
i got with this other organization that
allowed us to travel all over the world
and meet people like
nigel barker who took my my photo and i
was like so i'm like a top model and i
even i
am famous that he took my photo in like
2012
and i was that was really special and i
met kathy najimy um you know from hocus
pocus and sister
know that and yeah and she said she saw
me and she said oh you need to be in
everything tv film theater everything
and i was like thank you but um i really
didn't
put so much pressure on it because we
had come across a lot of like
famous people who said a lot of
compliments but nobody really acted on
it and she
was like do you want to do spoken word
to my daughter's music for joe's pub
and then i got to do that for a glamour
magazine event
and then she was like we're going to be
going to la do you want to come to la
and do some pieces and if you come to la
if you make your way to la i would get
you some meetings with
with some people casting directors and
like
um a commercial agent and so i met i got
with a commercial agent they were just
in la and they said well you know we
can't really do much for you because
you're in new york but we can send you
to
and i sent me to my first agent so i got
my first
agency around like the same time put
with
kathy and jimmy and with subvert it and
all of those
type of things that is the coolest that
one of the things that thrills me to
know and when i have these conversations
is just hearing about actors supporting
actors or really any role in the film
industry because i feel like
i don't know the the pressure is kind of
unbearable at points and unless
you have someone to help you out
sometimes it's easy to get buried under
it so the fact that there's people
especially
someone i admire like her supporting
someone else super talented like that it
really warms my heart
yeah for sure i remember it was like
actually i had a rehearsal with her
daughter like the day after
it was either the day of my college
graduation
or the day after but i was like i'm
gonna do this rehearsal and i
went down and we're just rehearsing the
song and then her
her husband and her daughter samia they
come out with a cake
and say she's a jolly good fella and it
has a candle on it to celebrate my my
graduation that was so sweet
you